well my friends i think we got bigger
things to worry about yeah
you want to know what those bigger
things are jack what if i were to tell
you that uh
you as a uh you you i'm i don't put
words in your mouth i understand it's
probably
obvious but you're a big trump supporter
i was drum sporter absolutely yeah um uh
what if they drown strike you
you know the thing for me is when i turn
on msnbc
you see where we're going everybody we
got a story and i watch nicole wallace
and and you hear some of the words that
are coming out of these folks mass and
it's amazing to me because
for all of 2020 this was the defund
police movement
and the cops in this country have it out
for uh for the little guy and their
their you know proto-fascists of a
police state the harbingers
of totalitarianism and we need to go we
need to get rid of them
you even have people saying abolish the
entire not just private prisons
but the entire prison system but then
they'll turn around and say
except for any of you guys in a red
hat i want all of you down at guantanamo
bay
i want waterboarding i want drone
strikes everything that's been done
to al-qaeda should be done to you and
this was what brings us to the actual
segment and why i asked you
that question from the blaze msnbc host
suggests killing american citizens with
drone strikes
and another story which you brought up
jack from the nation i'm for abolition
and yet i want the capital rioters in
prison
they're not for abolition they are
tribalists
they view you as an evil other who must
be caged or exterminated
and i know that might sound extreme but
this woman on msnbc
literally said when we deal with
terrorists overseas i mean we
drone-strike these people like american
citizen
anwar al-awlaki and then they go on to
talk about americans
what do you think they're referring to
let me show you the story from the blaze
they say during a discussion regarding
domestic terror msnbc anchor nicole
wallace floated the idea
of the u.s government killing american
citizens with drone strikes
something they have done before several
times in fact under obama
wallace brought up the national terror
advisory system bulletin that was
released to all law enforcement by the
department of homeland security last
week
the ball 10 which is in effect until
april 30th warns the dhs allegedly
received information
that there is a threat of ideologically
motivated violent extremists
with objections to exercise objections
to the exercise of governmental
authority
and the presidential transition as well
as other perceived grievances fueled by
false narratives
could continue to mobilize to incite or
commit violence
wallace notes quote there's a bulletin
released to all law enforcement earlier
this week
that there is until the end of april a
persistent threat of domestic domestic
extremism
she goes on to mention that basically
what they are what they already said
that the cover restrictions are
unnecessary all of those id ideologies
pushed by trump
the deadline white house host then said
but my question for you is around
incitement
we had a policy and it was very
controversial it was carried out under
the bush years and
under the obama years of attacking
terror at its root of going after and
killing and in the case of anwar
al-awlaki
an american yemeni american with a drone
strike
for the crime of inciting violence
inciting terror wallace said
mitch mcconnell was in the senate then
he was in the senate after 9 11 2.
how does mitch mcconnell who understands
the way you root out terror
is to take it on in the case of islamic
terror kill those who incite it
how does he not vote to convict someone
that he said on the house floor incited
an insurrection
the blaze then quotes uh a very poor and
stupid journalist lucrative
uh hey hey hey the blaze then shows
luke's tweet
where he says so they are pretty much
saying they have to stop incitement of
violence by inciting violence themselves
yes
this this is msnbc's nicole wall this as
msnbc msnbc's nicole wall suggests we
use domestic drone strikes on americans
as a solution to lockdown protesters it
may sound extreme
but please listen to that quote she says
mitch mcconnell
understands the way you root out
terrorism is to take it on saying
in the previous sentence killing in the
case of anwar al-awlaki an american
yemeni american with a drone strike
there we are i like how noah on mb msnbc
even batted an eye
as she compared anti-lockdown protesters
to terrorists i mean are you
freaking kidding me and this is again
nicole wallace a former bush
spokesperson and it's very interesting
that she brought up anwar alawaki
because that's one american citizen
abdul rahim alawaki is yet another one
he's a 16 year old american citizen that
was killed
under of course barack obama's drone
bombing he was 16 years old
and then donald trump who personally
called for a raid
under his raid killed his daughter who
was eight years old so we have
literally the entire assassination of
this
family and and a lot of people are
i mean i remember when when this was
being codified i remember when this was
first introduced and i was screaming on
the top of my lungs
hey this is extremely dangerous we
cannot give
the right to kill anyone that power we
can't give that to the presidency
he can't be judge jury and executioner
this is dangerous and it's going to turn
against the american people and now
today we have them on national
television telling you that it's a good
thing abdul rahman al-awlaki was the
american people
he was a 16 year old american he was
born in denver colorado and he lived in
san diego
he was a teenager apparently he was
looking for his grandfather and went to
visit yemen
and obama for some reason ordered a
drone strike on a civilian restaurant
killing this 16 year old why yep they
said it was an accident we were
targeting someone else
did anyone then ask why did you drone
strike a civilian restaurant
even if it was to get this target in the
mainstream media no
but of course we we are changed we did
we we went after robert gibbs we went
after
obama's spokesperson his right hand man
and we and we cornered him and we asked
him a number of times why'd you do it
why'd you do it
he finally snapped back and you can see
this in the we are change video
when you type in we are changed robert
gibbs he snapped back he said
he should have had a better father that
was the official justification
when the when the obama administration
was even denying it happened
here's my favorite thing is that uh
obama had the disposition matrix which
was
informally known as the kill list and i
think it was debbie wasserman schultz
you asked
i was like she's like she's like the top
democrat for the dnc or whatever and she
was like what are you talking about that
doesn't exist
no i asked her i was like how do you
feel about the president potentially
handing this power to kill anyone at any
moment
to potentially someone like mitt romney
she was like you're crazy
this doesn't exist what are you talking
about peter king a republican called me
an absolute lunatic and a [ __ ] for even
believing that there was such a thing
no one even wanted to talk about this
thing and then now it's
here and now it's codified and now it's
being promoted as some kind of great
amazing glorious idea to deal with
anti-lockdown protesters this is this is
crazy
i mean i i i that that's real like
yeah i i i mean obviously i can't talk
too much about my
you know uh actual uh yeah you worked in
intelligence yeah yeah you know service
but yeah that's that's
very very real the story the story from
the new york times was that obama was
given what looked like baseball cards of
statistics and like age and a breakdown
and threat level and then he would be
like oh
kill him and uh well uh more like the
nfc
not not not necessarily obama himself he
would eventually have to sign off but it
would be the nsc
um going up and in some cases the
national security security council
um which is attached to the white house
they're in the eeob building but
it's it's a white house uh organ in a
sense and the nsc was
greatly expanded under barack obama for
purposes like this and barack obama
personally signed off on a lot of these
drone strikes personally executing them
and he even came out a couple weeks ago
saying i kind of regret being as
aggressive
as i was with foreign policy because i
was trying to impress the republicans so
i could look tough in front of them
that sounds like a cop-out to say the
least especially when you have blood on
your hands and you killed american
citizens just because of your signature
well that's killed american teenagers
based on your signature and again donald
trump started his presidency
not in a good way because he also
personally signed off on a raid
that killed his eight-year-old daughter
right that's right yeah the
the eight well the eight-year-old sister
of abdur manalaki and the daughter
oh and anwar and not only were these uh
in some cases u.s citizens but another k
and you mentioned the restaurant right
you know the collateral damage in some
of these things there were funerals
weddings i mean these are clearly one
last thing
i need to add to this point because when
we look at these policies
syria iran uh you know afghanistan libya
they're all failed
but specifically when it comes to the
drone bombing campaign it came out
through many reports that
over 90 percent of the drone bombs
landed on
unintended people killed innocent
people that were not the intended
targets so this is the program that they
want to bring back
that they want to use in the united
states with a 90 percent fail list
is kidding me i gotta add two two very
important things here luke the first is
you you were trying to call this out a
decade ago i mean this was like almost
this is nine years ago two thousand four
so
where you you have people who uh in the
government who are doing this
and the fear was that as they started
killing american citizens it would
eventually find its way to american soil
the government's been empowered to do it
and now here we are yeah i mean ever
since 2004 i was saying the the war on
terror is going to be
going to be a war on the people and
that's exactly what we're seeing these
emergency laws being used now turn
against the american people
the only people who got this information
out there got my videos out there
where individuals like glenn greenwald
were the only few individuals that were
willing to share
these videos these confrontations with
robert gibbs with debbie wasserman
schultz with peter king and all these
other individuals
as the mainstream media stayed silent on
this issue and even denied the fact that
it existed and now the other point i
wanted to make
is that we recently heard from ken
cuccinelli that nancy pelosi wanted
crew served machine guns in dc
yeah what you need to understand about
the psychotic request
is that listen as most people who are
listening probably know
and many who are not big gun people
might not know all that well
it tends to be that those who are trying
to pass gun control laws know
nothing about guns and it becomes
particularly dangerous when they try
wielding them
because you end up with dumb people
saying things like fully semi-automatic
which is meaningless
or nancy pelosi saying automatically we
get
crew yeah automatically crew serve crew
served the machine guns
in a civilian jurisdiction you know what
happens
when you fire a machine gun okay let me
ask you what kind of bullet machine gun
does she wants well if they're crew
serve they're probably going to be what
like nato rounds
or what 556. she's certainly not saying
50 bmg full auto in dc is she
i think she was yeah regardless i don't
think she knows what she's talking about
let's say seven six two seven six twos
with the mt40s m60s
and will those go through a person
they'll go through many people yes and
then what's behind those people more
people and what's behind those people
more people and their children and their
families and cars and buildings and dogs
if you actually got this this is what
these people they don't care about well
actually though
at biden's inauguration that wouldn't
necessarily have been true because i was
there
but you know who wasn't there anybody
else right
the buildings are still you know the
buildings there and you know of course
all my co-workers thank god uh were you
know
everybody was safe but they locked that
thing down so much that this was like a
scene out of the hunger games
where which i was saying even before
lady gaga got up uh with the actual
mockingjay on her on her
address that there was
it didn't look like a [ __ ] it really
looked like the mockingjay 100 percent
look at the mockingjay
you know the capital has won the rebels
have been defeated
a nation mourns yeah and
you would look out onto the national
lawn and it was empty
yeah there were nobody there there was
it was
one or two rows of like a few
you know dignitaries and then media and
then just
grass and then so they decided to put up
these little miniature american flags
and state flags and different things
to make it look like there was something
there because you know remember of
course this was the huge controversy
in in the early days of the trump
administration about how many people did
he have
more than obama and sean spicer is going
through the numbers and all
but with biden there was nobody there
well they wouldn't let anybody go
right you couldn't get there right i had
to so my
studio was right there on constitution
ave so it was there for jan 6 was there
for january 24 20th
and that week the week of inauguration
for me to get through
it was complete military lockdown not
just
on the national mall or around the
capitol building like it is now
right now that was blocks and blocks
out you had to go through military
checkpoints i had to go through
tsa level secret service screening you
know the idea where you're they're going
through your bag
they're patting you down they're wanting
you i'd have my my media pass my media
credentials
and a list that i was on stating that i
was an essential worker this was the
building
and by the way if you were taking
pictures out there if you were
up you know hey let me just record some
of this seeing as i am
you're in a media capacity that you are
being hounded off the street hey
i said you were going to that building
get to that building you know well you
know i'm recording this for
for my job this is actually my work you
better get in there before
or we're going to revoke your
credentials like you didn't grant me my
credentials right
you know but that's the level that it
went to even if you were just doing your
job out there trying to show people what
it was like
on inauguration day it's always just
following orders
from the the lowest scale of just kind
of jamming you up at a checkpoint to the
the atrocities
i hear stories about national guardsmen
in dc who are extremely demoralized by
what's going on but it's not like
they're going to do anything well
they're not being forced to sleep in
parking lots
but but it's remarkable to me that they
could literally have
the as time magazine put cabal put them
in a parking garage with one bathroom
and one power outlet and no internet or
anything like that
and say sleep on the concrete and
they're like yes sir
it's it's i gotta admit the first thing
is it's actually admiral that admirable
that the net the guardsmen are willing
to endure this
in the name of of doing right by our
country but it's shocking to me
that people would actually follow the
orders and and i don't i don't know how
to say it
but that's why probably why i will
actually i will say this that shows a
failure of leadership on the officer
court right
that when you're an officer and i was an
officer you
are a leader of your soldiers your
troops your sailors whatever it may be
uh guardians i think this is for space
force guardians um
so if i'm in a situation where i know my
people are being asked to sleep in a
parking garage
you know i could understand going in
there on a movement and they said hey
let's be here for a little bit
you're asking me to sleep in there no no
no no no that's if i'm an o2 and i'm
gonna know three you know
uh you know um uh captain et cetera or
lower
you are going out there and i'm on the
phone with my major i'm on the phone
with my lieutenant colonel i'm saying
hey what's going on this is unacceptable
this is completely inappropriate is this
is this mission essential is it mission
essential for us to have to be in here
or not it's you got to take care of your
people
and it wasn't of course 26 000 people
listened and did what they were told a
lot of the back blue people are like
they're gonna not listen to all these
unconstitutional orders and i'm like you
have no
idea what you're talking about and you
have no sense of reality or
understanding of history
26 000 national guard troops over what a
threat alert
where did the threat alert come from was
there any legitimacy every time we
pushed
obviously they couldn't give us any
information nothing but this is
another big thing here threats it's
going to cost the taxpayers a half a
billion dollars
to pay for all that security close to
500 million dollars of our tax dollars
is going for this
security theater state that i know
you're we have different
understanding of this but but it is what
it is right now it's a big security
state
there's some troops standing behind for
other reasons and other purposes we
could talk about and speculate about
that later but a half of a billion
dollars
spent on that i want a refund i want my
money back no two thousand dollar checks
folks
i got a question i got a question for
you jack so the other day luke well
actually luke's made references to the
men who stare at goat several times are
you familiar with that that story
i've seen it like a million years ago
but yeah so it was actually a
non-fiction book i think in 2004
about this like program they did they
tried doing psychological
operations the jedi and stuff like that
it was called i think it was called like
the stargate project
now in the movie when it opens they talk
about how this guy
came to actually be running this psychic
you know unit or whatever right
and they said that when he was deployed
to vietnam they they you know they land
and then one of his
you know one of the soldiers gets shot
and he sees this woman running through
the field and he says what are you doing
shoot and then all of the men start
shooting
and they all aimed high and in the movie
they say they found out
that fresh recruits don't want to shoot
anybody
and often either subconsciously or
intentionally miss
and so they're all shooting high and
missing this woman and then she shoots
the guy bill and he falls down
and then he has a vision of like you
know using
gent uh the gentle nature of their men
as their strength or something
but what was interesting to me was this
idea that fresh recruits don't want to
shoot somebody i'm wondering if that's
true or if you're well that actually is
true
and i'm surprised you don't know do you
know how the dod
was able to overcome that first person
human targets for first-person shooters
wow human targets and first-person
shooters were
some of the ways that they
psychologically came
out during training of vietnam because
and this is back i remember this was
during the draft so a lot of people that
were forced to be there
they realized that you had to switch
from the
stationary you know ring targets that
you would have on the shooting range
to silhouettes to look make it look like
a person to condition you
to be able to pull that trigger to not
aim high as some of the original first
person shooters
actually came out of dod programs i
heard that before
and this was also done to be able to
start conditioning you that you know
it's it's okay this is normal this is
fine
because up until that point in human
history it had never been done before
this idea that
on a you know for kids right that we let
kids play first-person shooters
and that you're going to be conditioned
already from playing these games
that that's what you do and now now when
people go into the military
you're expecting it there's an
expectation that oh i'm going to deploy
and i get to shoot people and i get to
kick in doors and that's what joining
the military means
and so that's why you know you're asking
are they going to follow the laws you
like
you understand right we've conditioned
people to the understanding that joining
the military means i get to do these
things
they broke them down and built them in a
way where they will always follow those
orders thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you